on va parler tous les sujets le pouvoir
d'achat les fractures puisque c'est un
petit peu ce qu'a fait le terreau des
gilet jaune et c'est le thème de notre
club aujourd'hui ce mouvement était l'un
des marqueurs du quinquennat mais
aujourd'hui qu'en reste-t-il on va en
parler avec vous quelles réponses ont
été apportées par le chef de l'état le
mouvement peut-il renaître alors que ce
qui a fait son terreau ce sentiment de
délaissement cette hausse des prix
notamment du carburant et bien tout ça
est encore présent mais d'abord on va
revenir trois en arrière au début du
mouvement et jonathan tu du prix est un
rappel ce qu'il a été
septembre 2018 le gouvernement va mettre
le feu aux poudres avec cette annonce la
poursuite de la hausse des taxes sur le
diesel et sur l'essence le mois d'après
plusieurs anonymes s'en prennent à
l'exécutif sur les réseaux sociaux des
vidéos de vienne virales comme celle de
jacqueline moreau j'ai deux petits mots
à dire un monsieur vaincrons quand
est-ce que ça va se terminer la traque
aux conducteurs que vous avez mis en
place depuis que vous êtes là peu après
celle de ghislain coutard est aussi vue
des millions de fois et donnera son
identité au mouvement on a tous un gilet
jaune bagnols foot aller en évidence sur
le tableau de bord toute la semaine la
fin jusqu'au 17 partout sur le
territoire la contestation commence à
prendre en pleine célébration du
centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale
emmanuel macron voit ses déplacements de
plus en plus chahutée par des
manifestants affublés d'un gilet jaune
la première manifestation de grande
ampleur rassemble près de 300 mille
personnes en france le 17 novembre 2018
les ronds-points occupé peu à peu
devienne le signe distinctif du
mouvement tous les samedis les
manifestations s'enchaînent et se
durcissent partout en france les
cortèges sont émaillées de violences
celui du 1er décembre à paris on est le
paroxysme ce jour-là gilet jaune et
forces de l'ordre s'affrontent en bas de
l'arc de triomphe
le monument est pris pour cible
de son côté emmanuel macron tente
d'apaiser la colère sociale le 10
décembre 2018 après plusieurs semaines
de violences le président de la
république annonce une hausse du smic
200 euros et un gel de la hausse de la
csg pour les plus petites retraites taxé
d'être le président des riches emmanuel
macron tente de faire son mea culpa je
prends ma part de cette responsabilité
en 2019 le mouvement s'essouffle peu à
peu alors qu emmanuel macron se lancent
dans le grand débat national
la pandémie de kobe de 19 mettra en
pause les revendications des gilet jaune
mais ces dernières semaines le mouvement
ait said émerger à nouveau à moins de
deux mois de la présidentielle
[Musique]
et on l'a vu retour en arrière bruno
cautrès est-ce que ça restera forcément
des marques
c'est le plus important mercoeur à mes
yeux peut pas comprendre ce qui est en
train de se passer dans le pays la
manière dont les français vivent cette
élection présidentielle en dehors de la
prise en compte de cette crise qui est
sans aucun doute la plus grave crise que
la france ait connu au plan son
fonctionnement démocratique
pendant plusieurs depuis de très
nombreuses décennies c'est sans aucun
doute inégalé au plan européen on n'a
pas le souvenir en europe d'un autre
pays qui a été touché par une telle
crise sociale démocratique donc c'est à
la fois le plus important marqueur c'est
le tournant du mandat d' emmanuel macron
et c'est toujours là c'est ça n'a pas
disparu du tableau récemment dans l'
enquête qu'on a publié au cevipof le
baromètre de la confiance politique on a
demandé aux français s'il se sentait
toujours gilet jaune dont 1 6 % de
français qui se déclarent gilet jaune et
on en a 33 % qui se déclarent
sympathisants ou proches déjà les jeux
et on voit quand on quand on regarde les
faits que ça sur l'opinion sur le
fonctionnement démocratique de la france
on voit que c'est absolument majeur
comme eiffel et les français qui se
sentent toujours proche des gilles
jeunes ont un sentiment d'insatisfaction
sur le système démocratique le
fonctionnement de la démocratie on va
parler souvent on va parler de tout ça
d'aujourd'hui où on en est mais d'abord
pour vous aussi l'union c'est le
marqueur de ce quinquennat ça c'est pour
ça que la question numéro une qui
préoccupent les français dans cette
élection c'est pouvoir l'achat des
gestes ont été faits ils ont été
rappelés c'était pas la hausse du smic
200 euros - la prime de la prime
d'activité lorsqu'on a un smic ce qui
est pas tout à fait la même chose mais
il ya eu des gestes qui ont été faits il
ya eu des milliards qui ont été
débloqués quand même plus de plus de 15
milliards c'est à ce moment là
maintenant le la question est quel
débouché politique c'est ce mouvement
peut avoir
trois ans plus de trois ans après les
des candidats qui ont soutenu les gilet
jaune que ce soit l'extrême droite à
gauche
aso à l'époque et on sent qu'il ya pas
eu pour l'instant il n'y a pas une vraie
réponse politique à ce mouvement là et
on verra comment
souvent dans l'histoire française c'est
ces quelques années après qu on voit
quelle est la force politique qui
récupère la force sociale qui c'est qui
s'est manifesté quelques quelques temps
avant on le verra dans cette dans cette
élection et puisque vous parlez des
réponses politiques on va voir quelles
réponses ont été apportées durant ce
quinquennat par emmanuel macron parce
que marion et a eu des mesures pour
tenter de répondre à cette presse des
jeunes voulaient effectivement et des
réponses qui ont été apportées en deux
temps on l'a évoqué dans le sujet dès le
mois de décembre 2018 dans l'urgence
pour éteindre l incendie puis ensuite à
partir d'avril 2010 9 à partir de la
synthèse du grand débat national cette
vaste consultation des français et les
réponses de l'exécutif elles sont
principalement économiques et vise à
revaloriser le pouvoir d'achat parmi
elles effectivement l'augmentation du
smic 200 euros grâce un élargissement et
une revalorisation de la prime
d'activité la baisse de 5 milliards
d'euros de l'impôt sur le revenu avec
une baisse de 3 points du taux
d'imposition pour la première tranche
celle des plus modestes cela concernait
12 millions de foyers avec un gain moyen
estimé à 350 euros par ménage cette
crise a aussi marqué le retour du
travailler plus pour gagner plus avec la
suppression à des cotisations sur les
heures supplémentaires pour tous les
salariés y compris les fonctionnaires
autre mesure la hausse de la csg
contribution sociale généralisée qui est
donc annulée pour les retraités les plus
modestes les petites retraites ont
également été un déclaré ans d'excès sur
l'inflation et le projet d'une retraite
minimale à 1000 euros a vu le jour autre
point la possibilité pour les caf caisse
d'allocations familiales de saisir
directement les pension alimentaire non
versée une problématique qui fragile les
mères isolées qui était notamment aux
nombreuses sur sur les ronds points lors
de la crise le gouvernement a également
annoncé le déploiement sur le territoire
de maison france service pour regrouper
dans les zones rurales et en un même
lieu à différents services publics 1123
maisons ont ouvert au 1er février 2021
et puis une autre mesure plutôt
symbolique la suppression de l'ena
l'école nationale d'administration
ouverte en 1945 l'objectif avec cette
suppression est temps de revoir le
recrutement des hauts fonctionnaires ça
c'est pour les mesures prises par le
gouvernement pour répondre à cette crise
des jeunes mais il ya aussi des demandes
des gilets jaunes qui ont été rejetés
par le gouvernement voilà comme le
rétablissement de l'usf l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes la reconnaissance du
vote blanc ou encore à la mise en place
d'un référendum d'initiative citoyenne
lerrick l'une des revendications en
forte des gilet jaune qui devait
permettre de faciliter la consultation
du peuple sans passer par le parlement
et pour terminer je vous propose de
réécouter le souhait du président
exprimé en avril 2019 lors de la
présentation aux français et à la presse
de son programme pour répondre justement
à la crise ce que je demande aux
gouvernements aux assemblées aux
partenaires sociaux aux élus de replacer
l'humain au centre de rebâtir une nation
de citoyens libres dans une europe plus
forte parce que je crois que c'est ainsi
que nous pourrons véritablement retrouvé
cet art si particulier
d'être français auxquels nous sommes
attachés là c'était ça aussi l'une de
ses résolutions replacer l'humain au
tiers des politiques mais parce que les
gilets jaunes c'était évidemment du
pouvoir d'achat et on va en parler mais
c'était aussi demandes démocratiques ces
français qui ne se sentaient pas entendu
qu'ils ne se sentaient pas écouté qui se
sentaient oublié
des politiques bruno est ce que ça ça a
été résorbée non la crise n'a pas été
résorbés ni au plan de ce sentiment de
dysfonctionnement démocratique ni
peut-être dans quelque chose qui était
encore plus profond dans cette crise dg
les jeunes qu'ils aient le sentiment de
ne pas être traité avec dignité et le
mot dignité a marqué beaucoup la crise
des gilets jaunes notamment le début de
la crise de gilet jaune après c'est vrai
que toutes les violences inclus ont pris
le dessus on va dire qu'au début cette
question de la dignité on ne peut pas
vivre dignement du fruit de son travail
était quelque chose d'absolument
essentielle et c'est vrai qu'on la
demande de de vivre dignement du fruit
de son travail et une demande qui est
fondamentale et sans aucun doute que les
réponses apportées par l'exécutif n'ont
qu'un complètement apporter là la
réponse donc là de ce point de vue là le
sentiment de vivre dans une société
française qui est injuste qui ne délivre
pas finalement sa promesse d'égalité
républicaine de méritocratie qui ne
reconnaît pas les mérites qui en tout
cas attribue les mérites à ceux qui ont
déjà beaucoup est un sentiment qui est
omniprésent dans les toutes les données
des enquêtes que nous que nous réalisons
à sciences po vraiment quelles que
soient les enquêtes on voit que ce
sentiment est toujours là il maniait le
maquereau a lui-même reconnu un jour
d'interviews sur le porte avions charles
de gaulle qui n'avait pas résolu la
crise démocratique française et
récemment dans les enquêtes que nous
publions on a les deux tiers des
français qui disent que la démocratie ne
fonctionne pas bien en france que c'est
une belle promesse qui ne tient pas au
fond et bien qu'ils ne dans la réalité
ne tient pas tout c'est toutes ses
promesses alignant sur cette question
démocratique qui est aussi important
pour les jeunes oui pas eu du tout de
l'apport de moc rating sous pourtant la
consultation site la consule grand
départ le grand débat c'est eh oui mais
s'il n'y a pas eu de réforme ou de
changements profonds qui ont été
décidées par emmanuel macron après on
n'a pas de référendum d'initiative
citoyenne on a toujours est de faire de
sétif populaire qui est impossible à
mettre en oeuvre on l'a vu avec
là la nationalisation la privatisation
de paris c'est impossible à mettre en
oeuvre et encore quand on arrive à 4
millions de signatures il ya toujours le
clic et du parlement qui empêche de
toute façon toute consultation populaire
donc il ya un vrai sujet de
huy démocratique la question de la
représentativité la question de la
proportionnelle tout ça n'existe pas ça
peut être un vrai chantier
est un vrai débat dans cette campagne
présidentielle que pour l'instant on n'a
pas non plus
sur cette question
elle a pas finalement marqué un lien en
tout cas un tournant dans la relation
entre emmanuel macron et les élus locaux
est-ce que là il n'ya pas du positif à
tirer c'est clair que les images que
vous remonterez sont symptomatiques
effectivement de ce tournant c'est à
partir de là crise et gilet jaune que
l'exécutif redécouvre les élus les élus
locaux et on se rappelle tous du premier
débat animé par emmanuel macron pendant
plusieurs heures six heures sept heures
autant que je me rappelle un grand
boulot emmanuel macron va dialoguer avec
les élus locaux et on va voir la figure
du maire en particulier qui va revenir
en force ça va avoir un vrai fait sur la
suite du mandat d' emmanuel macron parce
que rappelons nous que derrière dans la
deuxième crise celle là crise de la
deûle à coville à nouveau cette
problématique de du système de
gouvernance on va dire le bon niveau
pour décider on va voir à nouveau les
maires revenir sur le devant un
changement de premier ministre qui
officiellement est motivé par l'idée
d'aller trouver un premier ministre qui
incarne davantage qu edouard philippe
qui pourtant était amer qui incarnerait
davantage qu' edouard philippe
finalement cette soupe ce binôme l'état
décentralisé avec le préfet et puis le
maire donc effectivement c'est un vrai
tournant de ce point de vue là mais là
encore on est un peu au milieu du on est
un peu au milieu du chemin au sortir de
tout ça ne s'est pas très bien quelles
sont les grandes leçons que l'on tire de
tous de tous et de ces deux crises sur
le système de gouvernance français est
ce qu'il faut le réformer est-ce qu'il
faut l'amendé est-ce qu'il faut
introduire quelque chose une rupture
très importante sur qui doit décider de
quoi à quel niveau c'est pas forcément
le millefeuille administratif ça peut
être ou est-ce que c'est efficace de
décider on en sait on ne sait pas très
bien où on est et justement puisqu'on
parle des élus locaux on va aller voir
un maire on va voir le maire de
saint-etienne gabrion merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin gaël perdriau
est ce que pour vous cette crise des
gilets jaunes a marqué un tournant dans
la relation entre emmanuel macron lmr
coûté toujours je pense qu'il est
insuffisant c'est à dire qu'avant les
gilet jaune il est certain qu emmanuel
macron ignorait les mères voire même les
méprisait les gilet jaune puis comme
vous l'avez dit à l'instant la cua vides
ont fait comprendre les maquereaux qu'il
avait besoin des mers et finalement nous
a simplement à ses yeux rendu utile mais
on ne peut pas dire encore aujourd'hui
que les maires soient considérés par
emmanuel macron il ya énormément de
décisions qui sont prises sans
véritablement qu'on soit consultée ou
où nos contributions soient prises en
compte dans les politiques publiques
tribune que vous avez publié il ya
quelques jours c'était dans le monde
vous alarmer des ravages qu'on traîne la
fragmentation de la société que vous
observez vous évidemment en tant que
maire est ce que pour vous cette crise
des gels et jaune est loin d'être
refermé est ce que le terreau est encore
là est ce qu'elle peut renaître et de
quelle manière
totalement parce que d'abord on voit
bien les réponses qui ont été apportées
ont été des réponses d'ailleurs je vous
avais dit non c'est l'époque
conjoncturelle on n'achète pas
une révolution tel qu'on est en train de
la vivre par des chèques de sousse en
euros ou quand bien même de 2000 euros
comme et macro chercher à y répondre en
fait nous sommes en train de vivre
véritablement une révolution en raison
de la présence du numérique qui prend de
plus en plus de dans nos vies également
dans l'entreprise et je la compare à la
révolution industrielle sauf que la
révolution industrielle c'était aller on
connaît bien à saint-etienne s'est
étalée sur deux siècles et elle a permis
finalement à d'êtres humains de
s'adapter de se former et puis le
processus de destruction des emplois
d'un côté été compensées par la création
de nouveaux emplois de nouveaux métiers
or cette révolution numérique qui est
apparu dans nos vies et maintenant vingt
ou trente ans avec beaucoup de brutalité
et de violence aujourd'hui on s'en rend
compte elle est beaucoup plus rapide
elle ne permet pas aux individus de
s'adapter finalement à la nouvelle
société qui est en train de se créer et
donc elle va laisser sans doute des
millions de personnes sur le bas côté du
chemin qui se sentent quelque part
inutile dans notre société c'est
d'ailleurs le message des gilet jaune
c'est qu'on travaille parfois dures
parfois en trois huit et à la fin du
mois on peut finalement on ne peut pas
s'offrir des petits plaisirs en famille
parce qu'on n'a pas suffisamment
d'argent on n'a pas de quoi payer
l'essentiel le minimum pour pouvoir
survivre et en fait ce que je crois que
tant que le président de la république
tant que le gouvernement tant qu'un
candidat à la présidentielle n'aura pas
répondu à cette question fondamentale
des mutations finalement du travail que
nous sommes en train de connaître et
bien tout cela sera vain et inutile ce
sera du vernis mais absolument pas des
réponses de fond et puis il ya la
question également de la valeur de la
parole publique et manu maintenant a
lancé le grand débat saint-etienne il ya
pris sa part avec des cahiers de
doléances nous avons organisé de
nombreuses réunions publiques avec
l'état mais qu'ont ils fait qu'est
devenue la loi sur la lutte contre la
pauvreté par exemple je représente
l'association des maires de france au
comité national de lutte contre
l'exclusion depuis deux ans et demi il
ne s'est absolument rien passé et même à
cran avait promis que plus personne ne
dormirait
hong kong est il cinq ans après et donc
ses paroles de la ccl crise de la parole
publique sans doute elle explique aussi
cette forte abstention qui se prépare et
malheureusement on le voit aujourd'hui
dans le comportement des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle on ne prend
pas le chemin d'un renversement quand et
je lis avec beaucoup de tristesse parce
que j'aurais retiré qu'il en soit
autrement valérie pécresse quitte le
parti en 2019 en raison de la
droitisation du parti et qu'elle revient
parce qu'elle lui permet d'être
candidate en adoptant les thèses qu'elle
avait combattu et bien c'est de nouveau
une expression de la clis de la parole
publique qui à mon avis très saoul
décalage entre les français et le
pouvoir mais ça veut dire gaël perdriau
perdriau pour être clair et pour aller
jusqu'au bout de leurs rêves votre
raisonnement que vous ne soutiendrait
pas valérie pécresse dans cette élection
présidentielle
on est en lutte à des
discours qu'elle tient je ne le peux pas
puisque cette droitisation du parti
allait adibou c'est évidemment par par
ciotti par morano part à d'autres aller
chasser sur les terres de ses droite
identitaire qui cherche l'union des
droites à tout prix et quand je dis à
tout prix c'est également au mépris des
préoccupations principales des français
à france urbaine l'association qui
réunit les grands les maires des grandes
villes de france je peux vous dire que
conçoit d'ailleurs de droite de gauche
ou d'ailleurs on connaît bien les
préoccupations des français et ce sont
celles des questions dont je parle du
travail des questions de solidarité dans
journée un petit peu marre qu'on
l'assimilé trop souvent à la question de
l'assistanat parce que une personne qui
vient chercher un succès
pour être clair pour être clair parce
que vous avez été si critique avec
emmanuel macron dans cette interview qui
soutiendrez-vous
aujourd'hui écoutés je les retrouve dans
aucun discours qui est porté par les
candidats les sons présidentielle entre
une droite c'est qu'ils cherchent encore
une fois à tout prix l'union des droites
et à ne faire d'eux des questions
d'immigration avec
beaucoup de propos quand même raciste de
plus en plus qu il encore se fragmente
encore davantage finalement la
population française et la société
divisée pour espérer régner sans doute
mais à quel prix et puis une france
néolibérale les manuels mâcon qui laisse
la classe finalement une mondialisation
qui écrase le la population des
habitants le bug je me retrouve pas
merci merci galles quadrio merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous maire de
saint-etienne est et de nous avoir parlé
de tous ces sujets on va terminer avec
cette question aujourd'hui que deuxième
mais gilet jaune c'est le thème
justement de notre reportage à votre
rencontre jérémy huntsman nous emmène à
la rencontre de ces gilet jaune
historique dans leur fin 2018 il était
particulièrement mobilisée dans ce
département aujourd'hui ils sont moins
nombreux sur les ronds points mais
certains sont restés actifs faisant même
évoluer le mouvement vers un réseau de
solidarité pour faire face à la hausse
des prix
verneuil dans le sud de l'eure 8000
habitants ses rues son église et son
rond point entre paris et rennes que
jean-marc connais par coeur sur la route
en novembre 2018 il l'occupé avec
d'autres gilet jaune on avait toujours
au moins 2 300 personnes continuellement
sur le rond-point il y avait même des
gens qui menait la nuit aujourd'hui le
mouvement s'est essoufflé mais pour jean
marc les revendications restent intactes
trois ans et demi après non seulement le
pouvoir d'achat n'a pas été résolu mais
la perte du pouvoir d'achat s'est
amplifié et c'est pour ça que le père le
mouvement va perdurer dans le temps
parce que vivre mieux plus décemment
c'est une chose légitime face à la
flambée des prix l'ancien buraliste a
pris les choses en main une fois par
semaine il arpente les routes pour
distribuer des paniers de fruits et
légumes en surplus il ya des légumes qui
sont en train de se perdre autant
essayer de récupérer pour en faire
bénéficier les gens on touche sur vernon
lui-même environ 120 personnes
zizou je fais la distribution ce tous
les jours franju
ce réseau d'entr'aide sabrina également
gilet jaune qui participent et en
bénéficient
peut-être que cette semaine j'aurai
autre chose ou peut-être à peu près les
mêmes choses je sais pas mais bon en
tout cas ça dépanne bien parce que vu
prix des légumes au commerce
c'est trop fort mère au foyer elle a vu
toutes augmenté ces derniers mois
l'électricité par exemple donc ça fait
mille quatre cent trente années on
oublie les loisirs les restaurants bas
toute façon
son oubli aussi vaut mieux mais manger
ce qu'on a à la maison et puis
d'ailleurs comme ça qu'on fait on essaye
de faire les fins de mois pour se
déplacer sabrina qui habite à 10km de
verneuil n'a pas le choix elle doit
prendre sa voiture ça a cassé
l'intérieur je pars a les moyens de
réparer pour l'instant avec son mari ils
dépensent 500 euros par mois en
carburant une fortune et une raison pour
eux de continuer à protester tant que
l'on n'aura pas une vie plus stable
financièrement meilleure
je quitterai pas mon chien mange les jo
nous on masque jaune au tour de verre i
la mobilisation a traversé les classes
sociales
donc je vois la tour de la madeleine est
là mais les premiers chiffres des choses
enseignante à la retraite corinne et la
mémoire du mouvement avec son appareil
elle l'a photographié de la normandie
jusqu'à paris j'ai trouvé ça beau j'ai
trouvé ça
un élan de fraternité un élan aux
révolutionnaires en quelque sorte
un élan prolongé par le convoi de la
liberté le week-end dernier le groupe
manifester sur les champs elysées comme
il y a trois ans le convoi de la liberté
c'est les enfants des gilets jaunes ils
ont enlevé leur gilet tout simplement
parce que c'était dangereux mais
n'empêche que la couleur elle est restée
dans notre coeur ils ont découvert sur
ma cocotte minute mais il est certain
que quand le couvercle va être retirée
parce que ça risque d'être d'exploser et
beaucoup plus que en novembre 2018 une
explosion qui pourrait se produire dans
les prochains mois selon eux notamment
si emmanuel macron est réélu
on le voit le terreau il est encore là
les jeunes sont encore là effectivement
ce mouvement pourrait repartir c'est en
tout cas ce que disent c'est gilet jaune
ça veut dire que aujourd'hui rien n'a
été résolu
des choses ont été résolu le problème
c'est que on vient on sort de deux ans
de pandémie on va revenir à une vie
politique économiques plus normales et
avec des règles économiques et qu'ils
vont se réinstaller on ya un cour des
comptes audi même si le gouvernement
veut rester dans les clous qui s'est
engagée au niveau européen il faut faire
1 9 milliard d'économies par an de ce
milliard d'économies par an c'est
beaucoup ce qui a été mis sur la table
tout à l'heure où le rappeler ces 15
milliards donc s'il faut derrière tous
les ans faire quasiment 10 milliards
d'économies il va y avoir d'autres enfin
des personnes qui qui ne m'ont plus
qu'ils n'ont pas s'y retrouver non plus
qui va faire les efforts et c'est un peu
l'enjeu notre société dans les années
qui viennent donc ces gens là qui sont
victimes aussi d'inégalités sociales
ne vont ne vont pas s'y retrouver et
peuvent retrouver cette solidarité qu'on
a vu cette expérience pour relancer un
mouvement pour conclure bruno parce
qu'on a vu dans ce reportage est
effectivement les gens sont là cette
solidarité est encore là ils sont prêts
à repartir est-ce que
choisit aucun des candidats est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une forme
d'impasse oui je trouve que ça
caractérise beaucoup la situation
politique que nous vivons un sentiment
d'impasse plusieurs enquêtes d'opinion
il ya plusieurs mois disait que les
français n'avaient pas envie de voir le
match retour de 2017 beaucoup
d'électeurs trouve que ils sont perdus
dans l'offre politique
emmanuel macron a fait le job pendant la
crise qu vide mais qu' il voudrait autre
chose mais il trouve pas quoi dans autre
chose donc effectivement il ya un
sentiment afin de de confusion qu est ce
qui nous arrive pourquoi la france se
connaît des crises à répétition ça
faisait ça fait maintenant plus de trois
ans que la france a connu une succession
de crises et sentiments aussi un peu
d'impasse politique on ne voit pas au
fond les alternatives le ce devait se
dessiner la preuve en est que des sujets
de préoccupation majeur par exemple
l'écologie par exemple la justice
sociale ne trouvent aucun débouché
finalement et envoie que des candidats
qui sont porteurs de ces questions qui
importent aux yeux des français
n'arrivent tout simplement pas à percer
dans l'opinion pendant cette campagne
[Musique]